[Music]
hey stepdads and dads don't always get
along but dusty and I have this code add
thing on lockdown
you make treats for tonight right I'll
hit the bacon on the way to the pageant
bakery let's you don't want to go to the
bakery
no I'm usually when you repeat what I
said and you shake your head up and down
it really means you don't want me to do
it I'm just thinking what may be
homemade no problem daddy homey and
snickerdoodles come right up hey hope
you drew again you better count Chuck
gee thank you so much for the cocoa hey
guys got a big surprise for you this
year Christmas both families together
hello grandpa Kurt
look your father hasn't met the new of
all dusty that's exactly the stuff he's
going to make fun of us for you'll see
dear God
[Music]
dress is so cool that I can't picture
I'm actually going shopping
[Music]
there you go bring the car round on the
curb this is Sarah's husband why is he
here
Oh cuz my dad's coming too
[Music]
has seen his dad in a long time it's
only been two weeks but it feels like
gosh doesn't it
this guy's raising your kids have to
find I got a good one for you two dead
hookers wash up he's done a real
Christmas bro he's Helene the only
person that can ruin your Christmas is
looking back at you from that mirror
well let's see a super sorry right here
yeah there we go
mm-hmm still you bet
[Music]